- Look who's here!
(swish)
- It's me!
- It's Colleen!
Are you going by Colleen Evans?
- Sure?
Depends on the day.
I'm so excited to be
shooting this video with you
because I think that you are
an expert in this area.
And the area is family.
(sighs)
- That's such a huge compliment!
- Oh, you're welcome!
And her sister is directly to the right.
- She is!
- Having a great time.
- [Hannah] Whoo-hoo!
- That was Hannah's impression of--
(laughing)
It is now becoming holiday season.
When is it actually considered
the start of holiday season?
- It depends on how depressed you are,
because I feel like--
- Seasons come and go,
but family is forever,
and so during the holiday season
you have to spend time with your family.
So I asked you guys on Facebook
if you needed any advice
on how to be around your family
during the holiday,
and we're gonna help you out!
- Facebook?
That's so mod of you!
- I know!
I felt like it's all in the theme.
How to convince your family
you love the food they made for you...
And the gifts they give you!
- That's really hard.
- Gifts are easier than food,
because all you have
to do is say thank you.
Giving gifts is literally just the moment
of interception of gift.
That's all the family member wants
is that moment.
- I know what you can do for the food.
- Okay.
- You make it a challenge.
'Cause if it's about the views,
you'll work harder to get it down.
You'll be like, "I gotta get those views!
"Gotta win this challenge!"
Grandma's cranberry sauce challenge!
Think about your family
as people with the potential
to subscribe to you.
- Yeah.
- You really gotta make them like you.
I naturally (and unfortunately)
attract children.
And kids are disgusting and annoying.
How do I not have them want to be
constantly hugging me or holding my hand?
- Oh, no.
When you first started reading that,
I thought it was going
in another direction.
- You love children.
- I love children!
- Okay, we have a varied
opinion on children.
(laughing)
- I love children!
I enjoy children to
climb, and like, play--
- Can I--
Why?
- Well actually, you know what,
that's not true.
I enjoy the children in my family.
There are children that I kind of
want to punch in the face a little bit.
- Yeah.
Just a little bit.
- Just like, kinda hard.
- Uh huh!
- Not that you would do any damage,
so that, like, if they went
to their parents and told,
there'd be no proof.
You know what I mean?
- Just the emotional scarring.
- That how hard I would--
Yeah.
- Let's say you're having an off day
with the kids in your family
that you normally like.
How do you convince yourself
to get along with them?
- You punch them just enough--
- [Grace] Skip suggestions
for relatives you barely know.
- Candles are always good.
- Oh, that's a great idea!
I have this new theory
that every holiday season
I'm just gonna buy numerous
varying amounts of
American Express gift cards
and just have them with me at all times.
- You know what I've done in the past?
- Uh huh?
- Is I've gone to family
events and been like,
"You know what would we should do?"
It's not even my party, and I'll be like,
"We should do a white elephant!"
So just bring one gift
and then you can just get, like,
a gumball machine that was $10 at CVS.
- What's the best gift that you've
ever gotten from a family member?
- Oh, I don't know.
I look to Rachel.
- Rachel!
- I hated her when she was born!
The best gift?
I don't know!
What's the best gift that
you've received from a family member?
- Oh, God.
Attention?
- Oh, yes!
That is the best gift anyone's gotten me.
Rachel got me, for my birthday, the--
I don't even know what it is.
Well how to describe
it, I will never know,
but it is, like, a little staue
of Jesus Christ surfing a wave.
She got it at the dollar store.
- I was gonna ask
where'd you get such a
beautiful piece of art?
How to stay sane and serene
when you and your boyfriend
are gonna get married
for the hundredth time?
(groaning)
- There is an evil
singing inside your body!
- It gets really mad about commitment!
I hate that, though!
I was recently married.
Was? What happened?
I got married
and I thought that would make that stop.
- And it doesn't?
- No, now people go,
"When are you having kids?"
(groaning)
Oh.
- Hey guys!
Comin' to you from the
set of Dirty Thirty,
our new movie.
Go to dirtythirtymovie.com
to register for updates on the film!
Hey, another great way
to ignore your family--
I mean, interact with your family
in a pleasant way over the holidays,
is to throw some headphones in
and listen to an audiobook!
Hey, where can you find an audiobook?
At audible.com!
They have over 150,000 audiobooks
on file for you to listen to.
It's just this easy.
I'm doing it right now!
You can listen to Binge book,
Tyler Oakley's new book,
which I highly recommend.
It's delicious.
Nutritious.
Easy to digest!
And you can get a free audiobook download
by going to audible.com/grace.
So why spend time in
there over the holidays
when you can spend time
out here, like this?
Look how fun this is!
Download your first audiobook
at audible.com/grace!
(moaning)
- Oh.
- Anyway, mafia, mafia.
Blah, blah, blah.
Advice on the best alcoholic beverage
that doesn't look alcoholic.
- Mmm...
- So I guess is the concept
is to be able to drink around your family
without them knowing that you're drinking.
- Vodka in a water bottle.
- That was quick and very thoughtful.
How do you handle family members
talking about politics
when you have very different viewpoints?
(groaning)
I think just that.
I think that's how you--
There you go, there was some
holiday advice for you guys
about handling your family members.
Thank you, Colleen,
for giving such great advice!
- Of course!
Any time.
- And make sure you guys one,
subscribe to our channel,
if you're not already,
and two, go check out the video
that we shot over there!
- We're gonna have underwear on our heads!
(laughing)
- Another great way to get out of
conversations with relatives
at holiday parties.
I don't know.
- I also like getting really close to them
and whispering something
that will scare them,
and then, like, walk--
like, you know, just being like,
"You're adopted."
Or just, "You're going to die."
You know?